um  memento this movie oh yeah yeah that's a  great movie  tricky movie but that movie you have to  watch a lot of time just to get what's  going on yeah it's because it's so  confusing for the usual suspects i i  think if you just get that it's  backwards it's not that confusing no no  no there's more things to get there  like is he the re the guy that you see  in the those flashbacks is he yeah  like  so many questions yeah so many questions  so few answers and i don't i don't even  know that you see that same  guy before in the story  but kevlar is saying spoilers so yeah if  you haven't watched memento stop  watching the stream  i'm just i'm just playing so bad  hmm  but when is it okay  okay i actually trapped this queen  amazingly  no it's not nice it's just lucky lucky  river that's what we do  queen g4 is still  fighting  okay not this way  knight f6  alright give a check i guess  okay now take this and this because yeah  bishop f3 and bishop c5  because